I mean I felt obviously really fantastic
I I probably felt if if I were to look
back and try to compare to any other
feeling that I've had before going into
a fight it was like super similar to
When I fought Marlin the first time
where like when I was in the back and I
was like no one will beat me tonight you
know like literally no one will beat me
that was the feeling that I had I've
kind of only had that on two occasions
one with Marlon and then one against
Cheeto because I think Cheeto even was
saying like physically he just couldn't
get going but his mind and I think that
physically I've learned how to peek
super properly like that will almost
never I feel like being an issue for me
because I figured that piece out
foreign
[Music]